NASCAR's Chicago street race is a
Daredevils Labyrinth
this weekend in the United States third
largest city for the first time anywhere
80 NASCAR drivers careen through
downtown skyscrapers at speeds up to 240
kilometers an hour this is a city street
where people take every day for their
commutes and tourists come to see the
beautiful fountains and the museums so
Each corner is different manholes
concrete asphalt so we got to tackle all
of it
for two days in two races some of the
world's best drivers who usually turn
left in a loop squeal around 12 turns
many of them 90 degrees over 3.5
kilometers with Lanes narrowing without
warning so you might go from a five or
six lane road down to a one-lane road on
these tight Corners drivers can throw
sharp elbows you don't complete a pass I
guess we'll come down and play a game of
chicken from four lanes to two lanes and
see who lifts and who doesn't protecting
Spectators in Chicago landmarks are 2
000 concrete barriers each more than
three meters long and topped by fencing
this isn't just a race this is a
festival with concerts and carnival
rides an exhibition of excess and speed
with muscle cars going way over the
limit through downtown streets on
Independence Day weekend and what could
be more American than that
some fear the race sends the wrong
message in a city with an illegal street
racing problem that spun out of control
under polluted Skies where ghost
bicycles dot the landscape where cars
have killed cyclists we think that
having a street race hosted in Chicago
at this time sends the wrong message to
drivers at a time where we really need
them to be slowing down amongst these
candies the sounds of NASCAR will Echo
for the stock car Association the
spectacle of a street race is an
opportunity
going to New Markets and introducing our
sport to new audiences so while we have
this really great fan base it's a
tremendous opportunity to expose a whole
new audience to NASCAR
the road to success is long windy and
full of potholes
but with a three-year contract with a
Windy City NASCAR has two more years to
get the Chicago street race over the
Finish Line John hendren Al Jazeera
Chicago
the basketball World Cup starts at the
end of next